let's go instead to us area code two
four zero two four zero go ahead
hello that mean that's you who's this
hey it's Adam again I called a few weeks
back if funnily enough it was the one
where there was like screaming and
writhing in pain in the background okay
yeah that was my mother I accidentally
closed my car door on her okay well okay
okay what's your question all right so
my question is I actually saw a recent
video that the humanists report had put
out um it was actually in regards to the
GOP tax plan from a few months back okay
and it actually reminded me of a
question I meant to ask you I have well
in regards to a tax build how can that
happen Ben any time two words this
correctly any I guess any text within
these bills that kind of tie the tax
cuts for like corporations and things
like that towards job creation
specifically you know how there's
there's always the rhetoric of oh you
know the tax cuts for the rich and for
the corporation they'll create jobs
yeah with with said windfall but you
know usually it never happened why
hasn't why haven't like Republicans or
even Democrats proposed sort of an
amendment to these bills yeah saying oh
you know I think I got it yeah listen
yeah politically it's totally
intractable nobody would go for it
number two the companies have admitted
that they're really not going to use the
money to create jobs because that's not
how economics works and number three I
think it would be really difficult
because the companies if you believe
that the tax cuts will lead to jobs you
need the tax cuts first and then the
jobs so the companies would have to
agree to take the money and then if they
don't create the tax cuts there would
have to be some way of then getting the
money back from them and just it's very
difficult nobody would agree to it they
mostly all know that it doesn't even
really work so I think it's just it's a
it's an interesting idea but I think
it's a total non-starter
okay all right I got you I also have one
more question I know you um I know
you're into art you've been you know
dabbling into cryptocurrency a little
bit do you think you have a little bit
of knowledge to give a little bit of
insight as to the UH I guess the market
on a cryptocurrency as it is right now
yes I would invest in cuc coin no I
listen dude I have no idea I don't I
don't give any financial advice on this
show and I'll probably lose all my money
I have in crypto and you know I don't
have anything - any recommendations
leave the financial advice - exactly
Pat's gonna give us financial advice on
next week's program so stay tuned for
that all right yeah it is a volatile
market so yeah high data and you know
all that stuff thank you for the call
really appreciate it